in the surrey commuter belt of embridge
the home county's so-called blue wall
however you spin it it's a bad day for
the tories
have you ever voted tori before i have
what made you vote for the lib dems this
time i think what i think
firstly what the tories are doing to
this country is shocking
i think that they've uh
been liars and cheats basically
why aren't you voting for the tories uh
lots of kind of bad press recently
how do you feel about the conservatives
no well actually not no just don't
really know which is weird because i
always have my family always
but now it's like yeah
they've been they've been bad yeah
the tories lost six seats here worse
than anyone had imagined four went to
the lib dems it was though a good day
for 18 year old harrison he became
surrey's youngest counselor but even a
rising tory star couldn't change this
party's fortunes
i think it says a lot about them you
know see more the character and what
they can offer rather than the age but i
also am honored by the people of
oakland's bird park who have put their
trust in me uh to to produce uh great
services to them yeah
but the thing you hear again and again
here is that tory trust is broken it's
difficult to make sense of local
elections but this is dominic robb the
deputy prime minister's seat last time
round at the general election in 2019 he
saw his majority slashed to less than
three thousand the tories undoubtedly
will be nervous looking at seats like
this and working out what all of this
means for the next general election
this remain voting affluent middle-class
middle-aged corner of surrey isn't
unique in places like oxfordshire and
berkshire the tories lost whole councils
in the south west somerset fell to the
lib dems an omen perhaps for a
by-election in tibetan nearby i mean you
look at party gate and everything like
that i mean it's not surprising that
conservatives are losing seats and that
labour and the libyans are gaining
ground even if even if you have respect
for a certain individual the fact that
they've
that they've supported johnson i
wouldn't i wouldn't um
that that's taking it far enough
it's in places like this that the tories
are coming undone and the lib dems are
seizing
believing now more than ever they can
get over the line in seats like this the
next time the whole country goes to the
polls ali forskou sky news elm bridge